there are currently 10.9 million
jobs open in the usa yet
millions of americans remain
unemployed house speaker
nancy pelosi says
many women in particular have not
returned to work because they cannot
afford child care
due to  Less child care is available because of the pandemic
and the cost of this
care is too much for some
families with male checks at 38
california congresswoman
djukic uld says child care
can cost as much as a third or half
of some people's income is because of
what Democrats say their plan
to spend $3.5 trillion is
crucial part of the plan would help
limit the cost of child care to
7 percent
of low- and moderate-income incomes in addition to
providing preschool for all children and
paid family leave benefits
measures Democrats say
will help families and the economy
since they will make it possible for mothers
to return to work, the
republicans are opposed to the plan and
some democrats like senator joe
manchin are also opposed to spending
3.5 trillion dollars, that is why
some parts of the package proposed by
the democrats are in  danger of being
eliminated reporting in washington
alexandra lemon